[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
just me flying solo today i did message
john about this didn't hear back but
here's the thing all right we've been in
this room for like 10 to 12 hours a day
for the past week between youtube and
patreon we cover a lot of tv shows and
that's on top of you know whatever else
comes out on youtube that we got to
cover if he's still asleep i don't blame
him i'm happy for him i slept in a
little bit later later than i normally
do i too suffer the consequences boy did
i get text messages this morning about
this spider-man event that is going on
do we know when the second trailer is
coming but there's a little bit of a
catch to it here's what's going on
trailer launch event with big surprises
tuesday november
16th at regal sherman oaks and by the
way um i i did say to many people and i
think i've said in previous youtube
videos that this trailer would come out
the tuesday the week that ghostbusters
releases that was just my feeling that i
had i think the last time i actually
laid down a prediction about when this
trailer would come out it would be the
tuesday of the week ghostbusters so i
win i win yeah tuesday november 16th 5
p.m is when it plays there 5 p.m pacific
standard time i full heartily believe
that it will be going online that day
because you can't trust fans when it
comes to spider-man no way there's been
so many leaks already you know that
there's going to be so many people if it
is just fans or or primarily just fans
once they get access back to their
phones they're gonna be revealing
everything that goes on in this trailer
they just gotta release it online don't
be silly sony here's the kicker regal
sherman oaks is only about nine minutes
away from where i live i know some
people who can probably if i just
really asked about it probably get into
this event but i say nay
no
i am not gonna go to this event i refuse
even coy messaged me about it this
morning i said no
i was literally like i want to do a
reaction to this it has to be a genuine
reaction look they're saying that the
trade of the launch event will have big
surprises there that has you
automatically thinking that there might
be cast members from there like tom
hollands and a uh right maybe john watts
will be okay but
we're all really thinking will toby
mcguire and andrew garfield be there
maybe maybe they will be and that'll be
awesome that'd be really cool i mean
that'd be a great way to be like all
right we've been in the not process for
a long time but here all three of us are
here to present the trailer it feel like
a real marvel fan event which would be
awesome but here's the thing on my
personal end i really do feel like
what's a big part of what's making this
spider-man no way home journey feels so
special is sharing it with all of you
the fact that
we've been like covering this movie
pretty much weekly for the like over a
year at this point leaks rumors
speculation photos trailers bits of
footage that we get yadda yadda yadda
interviews i was just thinking about man
if i was in there and even if toby
mcguire andrew garfield are there which
would be amazing to behold same time
it'd be like i wish i experienced this
trailer for the first time with all of
you might sound silly might sound cheesy
i know there would be a good amount of
people who'd be like why not if you can
go go go experience it there i respect
that but no i mean i've made my decision
i told coy like now i want to experience
it here with all of you i'm sure john
would echo the same sentiment as well
and uh let's see if koi goes to the
event or to get started in the video
with us that day anywho guys
what do you think about this and if you
live in l.a are you planning on going to
this or you plan on trying to go leave
your thoughts down below subscribe hit
that bell keep a look out for our
reactions at spiderman no way home
trailer see you guys